[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we gotta talk need to rethink this out
of my way Hunt Walker we got a problem
there's a storm when we eat enough talk
I'll see what parents
25,000 feet
I know what you're thinking maybe
they're not here for you maybe they're
just here for me are you willing to take
that chance you have something I want
right now that makes me the only person
you can trust to get you out of here
alive I think I'd like to go home now
[Music]
what do you think you're doing Erica it
may be your mission but this is the
CIA's plane it doesn't take off without
my say-so
we need reliable intelligence that we
did it now this scenario is precisely
why the IMF exists the IMF is Halloween
Alan a bunch of grown men in rubber
masks playing trick or treat and if he
had held on to the plutonium in Berlin
we wouldn't be having this conversation
and his team would be dead yes they
would
that's the job and that's why I want one
of my own men on the scene to appraise
the situation
agent Walker special Activities his
reputation precedes you use a scalpel I
prefer a hammer my man goes where no one
goes
there cannot be peace without first a
great suffering the greater the
suffering the greater the peace the end
you've always fear is coming it's coming
and the blood will be on your way I
prayed to go that it wasn't true
Solomon Lane escaped in Paris now the
world is at risk this is the CIA's
mission you use a scalpel I prefer a
hammer honestly he's not just some
observer he's an assassin
I trust anybody outside in this room
you go ro he's been authorized to hunt
you down and kill you
that's the job
no hard feelings
[Music]
what are you waiting for I'm jumping out
a window stops Ethan hands everyone I
ever cared about
you don't understand what you're
involved in you need to walk away
maybe we need that
[Music]
accepted either you've lost this one
with Stannis time
what's done is done what we say it's
done Showtime oh my god
you
you